إذا كنت تأخذ عبارة من ميكونوس ماضيًا
من معالم الأساطير اليونانية ، فسوف
تكتشف
جزيرة كاديا حيث ينسى الناس الموت
مكانًا يعيش فيه الناس حتى سن 90 عامًا
ومعدل يصل إلى 4 مرات أكبر من
الأمريكيين مع نسبة ضئيلة من
معدلات الخرف لدينا و  متوسط العمر المتوقع لمرض الزهايمر في
مريكا 79 يجب أن نع
ش جميعًا في 92 في مك
ن ما على طول الخط كنا نترك 13 عا
ًا على الطاولة وعندما وجد مس
كشف ناشيونال جيوغرافيك يُدعى دان بوتنر أن
ذا المكان تم النقر عليه ، لذا فإن سع
ي هو كيف نحصل على هؤلاء الـ 13 ال
ضافيين  سنوات وكيف نجعل تلك
السنوات الـ 13 الإضافية الجيدة التي أرسلها له سؤال واحد
في مهمة مدى الحياة
لإعادة أسرار أسعد
المعمرين في العالم في كل مرة
يجد فيها فريقه جيبًا من طول العمر كانوا
يدورون حوله على  خريطة بالحبر الأزرق
وتعلموا أنه في هذه المناطق الزرقاء ، هناك تسعة
خيارات رئيسية لنمط الحياة مهمة بنفس
القدر بالنسبة لأكثر من الجينات الجيدة ، حيث يمكنك
التخلص من التسعة تحركات بشكل طبيعي كل
يوم لتكون قادرًا  للتعبير عن إحساسك
بالهدف ، اتبع طقوسًا يومية تعمل على
عكس ضغوط الحياة اليومية ، تناول
القليل من النبيذ في الساعة 5:00 وتناول نظامًا
غذائيًا نباتيًا ، وخاصة الفاصوليا
والمكسرات ، تناول وجبة فطور ضخمة تنتمي إلى
مجتمع قائم على الدين ضع عائلتك في
المقام الأول
احتفظ بوالديك المسنين بالقرب منك وقم
برعاية مجموعة خاصة من الأصدقاء أربعة
أو خمسة أصدقاء سيقومون
بدفعك في الاتجاه الصحيح